celebrities dress up for the Met Gala
desperate Democrats Iike scandal and Joe
Biden dominates the polls I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
prepare for the meanest episode of the
Ben Shapiro show in history which is
saying a lot because I have some
comments on the Met Gala like a lot of
them and they're actually live summed up
I don't want to oversell this thing it's
gonna be good but first in quarter one
gold purchases by central banks were the
highest in six years in the face of the
dollars declining stature what are you
doing to protect your savings become
your own central bank move some of your
savings to gold it helps you protect
those savings can you afford another hit
to your retirement like the last
downturn when the S&P dropped 50% one of
the ways to hedge against inflation and
uncertainty and instability is with
precious metals Gold's a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group right now
thanks to a little-known IRS tax law you
can even move your IRA or eligible 401k
into an IRA backed by physical gold and
silver which is perfect for people who
want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from future
geopolitical uncertainty look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard savings I'm not
saying you should take all of your money
and put it in gold I'm saying take some
of it they Versa fie Birch gold group
has thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group get a free information
kit on physical precious metals see if
diversifying into gold and silver makes
sense for you this comprehensive 16 page
kit reveals how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move that IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds into a precious metals IRA if
that's something you're interested in to
get that no-cost no-obligation kit text
Ben to 47 47 47 again text Ben my name
too 47 47 47 for that free comprehensive
kit go check it out right now text Ben -
47 47 47 alrighty so last night was such
an exciting evening in the arts and
incredibly exciting evening in the arts
when everyone dresses up like a dope and
goes over to the Metropolitan Museum of
Art it's amazing the Metropolitan Museum
of Art's Costume Institute has a
fundraiser every year or basically they
somehow get all these celebrities to
dress like like fools and show up and
everybody who's in Oz at the ridiculous
and bizarre
outfits that these celebrities wear
nothing smacks more of the Hunger Games
Capital fashion than the Metropolitan
Museum of Art gala and there's something
deeply unsettling about the richest
socialists among us spending presumably
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
create some the ugliest crap ever put on
a human face or body and then strolling
into a strolling into a paparazzi strewn
room to show off these hideous outfits
all because they are so much better than
your there's so much better than I
there's so much better than everyone
this is what taste is now this year was
particularly ridiculous because the
theme every year they have a theme at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art costume
Institute this year's theme was camp
notes on fashion which is a play on
writer Susan Sontag seminal essay notes
on camp which I'll get to in just a
second
in 1964 according to NBC News sonntag
tried to make sense of the notoriously
hard to define aesthetic in her
bullet-pointed treatise by saying camp
is the love of the unnatural of artifice
and exaggeration camp she laid out sees
everything in quotation marks and is
something of a private code a badge of
identity camp is often over-the-top
gaudy
extreme and playful if all of this makes
you want to go full french revolution
and start executing the Aristo well
you're not alone this is the sort of
stuff where you wonder about the culture
gap in the United States this would be
it and the reason that this would be it
is because the very notion of camp was
designed as a way for supposedly
highbrow Metropolitan people to sneer at
the rest of America
that's what camp was originally and it
still feels that way it's why a normal
person looks at these costumes and think
these people look like idiots and yet
everyone in the arts like wow that's
just it's just gorgeous it's incredible
you feel like you're being gas-lit you
feel like you're being gassed like
because this stuff is not just hideous
it's stupid-looking
and it costs hundreds of thousands of
dollars and these same people are
complaining about kids who are starving
in health care that doesn't cover
everyone while they stroll around in
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
outfits that aren't even pretty like
this is this isn't even a fashion that
anyone would ever wear right none of
this stuff is fashion anybody would ever
wear all of this is just a playful sense
of irony now I am NOT a big fan of irony
of cynicism in
politics in art I find it off-putting
not only do I find it off-putting
I find it degrading because in your life
if you live your life in ironical
fashion if you live your life sneering
at everyone who is trying to be sincere
you're gonna make yourself pretty hated
pretty quickly most people are trying to
lead us in ceará life most people are
trying to lead an authentic life where
they believe the things they believe and
then live for those things most people
are trying to better themselves most
people are trying to increase their
status in the world play by the rules
what irony does unfortunately just as a
psychological kind of psychological
trait what irony tends to do is
downgrade all of that the more sincere
you are the easier it is to make fun of
you and this is why you will see those
in the arts mocking honest art mocking
the stuff they think is too simple too
innocent instead we have to sneer at it
the Fred Segal has a great book called
the revolt against the masses how
liberalism has undermined the middle
class what came out 15 years ago and he
talked in the book about the fact that
during the 1950s a period that the
American Left excoriates in hates the
American movement toward greater greater
culture was happening a pace so he
talked about how in the 1950s the
public's expanding tastes an increased
income produced a 250% growth in the
number of local symphony orchestras
between 1940 and 1955 in 1955 15 million
people in the United States paid to
attend major-league baseball games 35
million paid to attend classical music
concerts it's amazing so more people
almost three times as many people paid
to attend classical music concerts as
paid to attend a major league baseball
game the New York's Metropolitan Opera a
Saturday afternoon radio broadcast
through a listenership of 15 million out
of an overall population of 165 million
so people were spending enormous time
enormous money trying to better
themselves book sales doubled over the
course of this period NBC spent half a
million dollars in 1956 to present a
three-hour version of Richard the third
starring Laurence Olivier this is
precisely the same time precisely the
same time that so many people on the
Left were decrying America as a cookie
cutter middlebrow country in 1947 in
nineteen
forty-seven there's guy named Robert
Hutchins he was then president of the
University of Chicago an autodidact
philosopher named Mortimer Adler they
launched an effort to bring the great
books of Western civilization to the
people in 1948 Hutchinson Adler drew
2,500 people to a Chicago auditorium to
hear them lead a discussion of the trial
of Socrates by 1951 there were 2,500
great books discussion groups with
roughly 25,000 people meeting 50,000
Americans a year were buying collections
of the writings of Plato Aristotle the
founding fathers and Hegel at prices
starting at 300 bucks and topping out at
$1,200 and yet we were told by the
American Left that mass culture was
eating America and this is where camp
comes in the reason I'm reviewing this
is because notes on camp which is the
which is the inspiration for the
Metropolitan event last night note um
camp is an essay by Susan Sontag the
radical philosopher who once declared
that white people were a cancer and in
1964 in partisan review which was
basically a communist magazine she wrote
an essay titled notes on camp the essay
sent Susan Sontag name profile into the
stratosphere but basically her entire
theory was that people who were highbrow
had to basically mock people who were
attempting to learn more mock people who
are attempting to aspire to something
better culturally she wanted she she
said that camp was a rebuke to the
cultural Mandarin some people who are
trying to spread culture
she said it allowed people to be serious
about the frivolous and frivolous about
the serious
in other words highbrow people could
like lowbrow things so long as they were
ironical about it
so long as they looked down at everybody
who is attempting to better themselves
she said that there were new aristocrats
of taste she suggested that middlebrow
middlebrow living could be enjoyed but
only as long as you were mocking it
that's what camp really was in her essay
notes on camp she describes camp in sort
of a bullet pointed way she says camp is
a certain mode of aestheticism it is one
way of seeing the world as an aesthetic
phenomenon that way the way of camp
capital C is not in terms of beauty but
in terms of degree of artifice of
stylization where it's the elevation of
stuff that youth find beautiful so if
you find Beethoven beautiful Beethoven
is not
making fun of Beethoven is camp taking
it to the aesthetic extreme that's what
camp is to emphasize style is too slight
content or to introduce an attitude
which is neutral with respect to content
it goes without saying that the camp
sensibility is disengaged depoliticized
or at least a political in other words
content no longer matters it's the
emphasis on style that really matters
not only is there a camp vision set
Susan Sontag there's a camp way of
looking at things
camp is as well a quality discoverable
in objects and the behavior of persons
there are camping movies clothes
furniture popular songs novels people
buildings this distinction is important
camp I has the power to transform
experience but not everything can be
seen as camp it's not all in the eye of
the beholder and then she lists a bunch
of things that she considers part of the
Canon of camp women's clothes of the 20s
stag movies scene without lust or they'd
be pornography but scene without lust
because you're seeing with an ironical I
obviously camp taste has an affinity for
certain arts rather than others clothes
furniture all the elements of visual
decor for instance make up a large part
of camp and that she says there's a
sense in which it is correct to say it's
too good to be camp or too important not
marginal enough in other words the idea
of camp is to take unserious things and
treat them as serious and to take
serious things and treat them as
unserious it's to mock the idea that
there are standards to be upheld
that's what camp is all about says pure
camp is always naive camp which knows
itself to be camp is usually less
satisfying if all of this makes you want
to tear your hair up and it sounds just
like the intellectualization of bizarre
behavior
or it sounds as though it's a way of
making palatable to yourself the fact
that you're mocking fellow human beings
or simply trying to engage in art that
you're mocking the sincerity of other
people's belief systems which is by the
way what happens at the Metrotown
metropolitan museum of art show every
year every year there's somebody who I
remember a couple of years ago they did
a camp take on Catholicism and they were
taking all of these holy catholic images
and then they were mocking them with
camp as they're trading something
serious and using it playfully they say
in naive are pure camp
this is Sonntag the essential element is
seriousness is a seriousness that fails
of course not all seriousness that fails
can be redeemed as camp only that which
has the prop
mixture of the exaggerated the fantastic
the passionate and then ieave when
something is just bad it's often because
it is too mediocre in its ambition the
artist hasn't attempting to hasn't
attempted to do anything really
outlandish camp is the attempt to do
something extraordinary and she goes out
into very very long essay in partisan
review there there I kid you not 58
bullet points about camp her final one
is the ultimate camp statement it's good
because it's awful and then she says of
course one can't always say that only
under certain conditions
those which I've tried to sketch in
these notes camp taste is a kind of love
a love for human nature it relishes
rather than judges little triumphs and
awkward intensities of character camp
taste identifies with what is it what it
is enjoying people who share this
sensibility are not laughing at the
thing they label as camp they're
enjoying it camp is a tender feeling
well no camp generally is not a tender
feeling camp is generally you mocking
something but pretending that you're not
mocking that thing that's that's really
what camp very often is and you see that
in the upper brow tastes of the people
who are is that this is why again as
we'll show you in a second the costumes
the outfits that are deliberately ugly
deliberately stupid looking deliberately
ridiculous and then if you say that it's
well you you're not in on the joke it's
a camp as an inside joke guys the reason
I think this is important is because I
think that it does speak to the nature
of politics that we are that we are
sharing right now and we're seeing the
backlash to it I'm gonna get to more on
this in just a second because the fact
is the cultural wars that we have today
have deep roots going all the way back
to the 1960s and people like Susan
Sontag as I say Susan Sontag you know
that it's not a coincidence that Susan
Sontag really despised a lot of things
about America at the same time she was
coming up with this ironical mocking
notion it's a more on that in a second
first Mother's Day is coming up there's
absolutely not nothing most of us
wouldn't do to make sure the special
moms in our life are happy cherries
berries has special Mother's Day berries
designed just for Mom they're topped
with chocolate chips pink shimmer sugar
swizzles you choose your delivery date
to ensure mom gets your gift of Sherry's
berries exactly when you want her to and
your satisfaction is always guaranteed I
love the products of cherries berries
every time I bring home a box of
cherries berries for my wife appraoch oh
sure product from sharri's berries they
have some kosher stuff my wife is so
happy so are my kids I mean it's just
incredible stuff don't wait until the
last minute
on this deal visit berries come today to
order freshly dipped strawberries
starting in 1999 for the moms in your
life to make mom really happy you can
double the berries for just $10 more
Mother's Day is Sunday May 12th so visit
berries calm that's BER RI es calm click
on the microphone in the upper right
corner enter my code Ben show that's
Barry's calm click the microphone code
Ben show go check it out right now
Sherry's berries it is just some of the
best stuff in the world it's incredible
check it out right now berries calm
click the microphone code Ben show get
that special Mother's Day deal right now
so as I say Susan Sontag
who created the idea of Camp three years
later in partisan review would write
this if America is the culmination of
western white civilization as everyone
from the left to right declares then
there must be something terribly wrong
with western white civilization this is
a painful truth few of us want to go
that far the truth is that Mozart Pascal
boolean algebra Shakespeare
parliamentary government baroque
churches Newton the emancipation of
women Conte marks the Lynch in
Ballantine ballets at all don't redeem
what this particular civilization has
wrought upon the world the white race is
the cancer of human history it is the
white race and it alone its ideologies
and inventions which eradicate
autonomous civilizations wherever it
spreads which has upset the ecological
balance of the planet and now threatens
the existence of life itself so Susan
Sontag again had a deep level of disdain
for the American Way of life
she had a deep level of disdain for
capitalism obviously and she had a deep
level of disdain for objective standards
of culture and that's what camp is
really an ode to Susan's contacts notes
on camp is really an ode to the idea
that we should obliterate any
distinction between good and bad art by
pretending that bad art is so bad that
it's good and that good art actually if
we take it to its logical extreme is
mockable and should be treated with
irony and people who are trying to
aspire to objective standards of beauty
are really just flattering themselves by
the way I totally agree with Tom Wolfe's
characterization of Susan Sontag is
quote just another scribbler who spends
her life signing up for protest meetings
and lumbering to the podium encumbered
by her prose style which had a handicap
parking sticker valid at partisan review
it seems about correct to me now in a
second I'm gonna show you why this
matters okay so here are some we're
go through some of the pictures I'll
describe them to you from the stupid Met
Gala so the Met Gala this is to me the
Met Gala is basically the cultural
version of the white White House
Correspondents Dinner the White House
Correspondents Dinner is a bunch of
journalists who all agree with each
other politically getting together to
laugh at people in the middle of the
country who don't agree with them but
are too unsophisticated to be part of
the White House Correspondents Dinner
it's nerd prom it's the self flattering
display of insularity and that's exactly
what the Met Gala is it's people dressed
up like idiots if you saw somebody
dressed up like this walking down the
street you'd probably seek to have them
for incarcerated you probably seek to
have them at least they'd be put on a
5150 hold or I mean you'd actually want
to check into their mental stability but
now they show up and they pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars for these
particular outfits and then we are told
that this is the height of culture these
are people who understand culture that's
what these are people who understand
culture straight from the streets of
Panem pretty incredible so Katy Perry
for example dressed up apparently doing
some cosplay of Lumiere from from Beauty
and the Beast so that's pretty exciting
stuff she's dressed with a chandelier
around her head and then a chandelier
around her waist later apparently she
would dress up as a hamburger as well
this is all camp right now again what is
this supposed to do what's supposed to
play with you right it's supposed to
Gaslight you so you look at this and you
think what is wrong with this person
this looks ridiculous and then it well
you're not in on the joke guys if you
were truly culturally aware you would
understand that this is camp this is
high style and it's mocking it why can't
you just play with us why can't you just
be part of our ironical ironical
approach to fashion why can't you just
do all this stuff well because I think
that your ironical approach does not
merely extend a fashion I think that it
extends to politics as well I think that
there is a cultural gap that that
basically suggests you're in the
in-crowd or you're in the out crowd I
think that cynicism about art cynicism
about objective standards of beauty
cynicism about all of this stuff leads
to a great gap because there are
universals in human culture and yet we
are attempting to break down these
universals and it's irritating to people
who believe in the universal meaning
most people look at this crap and they
say it's crap but they are told no no no
you just don't know you're
unsophisticated you're a bore if you
don't understand why cardi B is dressed
up as
blood-vessel you don't understand by the
way cardi basically is dressed up as a
blood vessel she apparently is wearing
some sort of weird what is she like a
capillary system she's dressed up in a
in a giant feathered red cape apparently
I'd heard a rumor that there were bodies
that she had drugged under there and
she'll rob them later but we don't know
she's a sophisticate doke RDB we know
she's a sophisticate because of her
music which is incredibly sophisticated
and if you don't understand the
sophistication and you prefer to listen
to you know actual sophisticated music
that's because you don't understand the
nature of ironical camp then you've got
Lady Gaga who went through a series she
basically went through an entire career
change over the course of the Met Gala
she started off dressed as I don't even
know a person who was attacked by a
jellyfish she started off dressed in
this giant pink fabric thing with a
bunch of men holding umbrellas around
her and after she I guess she's the
Duchess of crazy lamb and then after it
turns out she lost her job as the
Duchess of crazy land she was reduced to
being a nanny so here she is his Mary
Poppins I guess wearing she's holding
her umbrella up high as she wears a
black dress and things gone really
really wrong for her ever since she
didn't get Bradley Cooper I guess and
then she downgraded even from that she
lost her job as a nanny and she was
forced to be a stripper which is too bad
so but then this is all obviously high
style guys and if you don't get the joke
that's just because you have no sense of
humor don't you understand you're like
why are all these rich people spending
lots of money well being socialists on
random crap and we're supposed to cheer
for them
why then that's because you don't
understand camp or irony guys Lena
Dunham dressed up in a in a dress
wearing rubber gloves and it says on the
front of her dress rubber wrist with a
picture of the rubber gloves I will
admit I was too innocent for this I did
not know what rubber ism is or what a
rubber wrist is apparently it's somebody
who has a rubber fetish good news the
rubber fetish is now over now that Lena
Dunham is dressed in this there will be
no more humans with rubber fetishes
after this particular outfit and then
Billy Porter showed up as well
so Billy Porter's whole shtick is to
show up apparently at large-scale events
dressed in
landish things this one hehe I guess
dressed is effectively the guy from 300
like the villain from 300 he's carried
in by a bunch of black guys with no
shirts who presumably are supposed to be
imitating slaves I'm glad that he's
allowed to get away with us and and this
is apparently the height of camp what it
what a fabulous icon Billy Porter is for
for doing this sort of stuff and then of
course you have there he is Billy Porter
dressed in eye candy as Birdman as
something from the the Rio de Janeiro
revelry yeah I'm confused and then
finally you get to Jared Leto till at
least at least I found this somewhat
hilarious this at least is funny so
Jared Leto is dressed in apparently some
sort of like 18th century Russian
Emperor costume carrying a double of his
own head he's carrying around his own
head in his hand but guys if you think
all of this is weird and off-putting if
you think maybe we've become too
prosperous to society as a result of the
fact that we are all looking at these
people and laughing at them and with
them then it's only because you you're
not in on the joke you wonder why the
Trump revolution happened now I know
it's overused this is why you got
trumpet this is the sort of stuff while
you got Trump because your cultural
betters will tell you they know more
about morality they know more about
decency they know more about how to
raise children they know more about how
your money should be spent than you do
all of these people are wandering around
holding replicas of their own heads at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art all of
them are walking around dressed as as
Persian princes being carried by Nubian
slaves or something at the I mean it how
do you get away with that at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art our cultural
betters the people who ought to tell us
what to do politically who want to
control our government top down those
people who want to centralize power and
tell us what to do are dressed as
chandeliers and if you don't understand
the joke it's because you're nuns you're
a non sophisticate you're a rube you're
a deplorable you're a person who lives
in the middle of the country you're a
bitter clinger claims those old values
of you know things like objective beauty
artistic value that there are a lot of
the ancients talked about the ideas of
objective values in art I think there is
a lot of truth to the idea that bait
toven is objectively better than cardi
be objectively better but when you break
down all boundaries and then you suggest
that the only boundaries are the ones
that you get to establish top down
you've created a system for chaos and
effectively in the arts a system of of
decimation of quality overall and then
you've cast out anybody who believes
that anything differently so I thought
that it was worthwhile exploring notes
on camp since we're all supposed to just
swallow the idea that camp is in and of
itself something wonderful and the Susan
Sontag is a wonderful addition to the
American Philosophical tradition and all
of this stuff by the way she's awful
writer I know that a lot of people
disagree a lot of people like her
writing you're allowed you're wrong in
any case well it gets what gets you some
more cultural issues of high irritation
to me today but first now it's time to
move on to my all-time favorite underdog
success story in the market I'm talking
about movement watches of course founded
on the belief that style shouldn't break
the bank they've sold almost 2 million
watches worldwide by bringing quality
designs at fair prices now I love
movement watches I own two of them
myself I've bought them for most of the
members of my family you guys know I'm
all about supporting ground up
entrepreneurs who work hard for and for
what they want that's why I love
movement they are a true success story
it makes wearing their products more
meaningful they came up and made a name
for themselves in one of the most
established markets in the world they've
reached exponential growth that's
amazing for a young team movement watch
they're all about looking good by
keeping it simple they're not gonna tell
you how many steps you've taken they're
not gonna blow your wrist up with text
messages they tell time like a classic
timepiece should and they look good
doing it movement watches start at just
95 bucks you're looking at 400 bucks for
the same quality from a traditional
brand got clean design minimal and
really quality product movement has sold
almost 2 million watches in over 160
countries yet 15 percent off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MVM t.com slash shapiro MDM t is
launching new styles on their site all
the time check out their latest at MBM
t-dot-com go to em VMT comm slash appear
for special deals join the movement
MVM t.com slash shapiro ok speaking of
cultural issues where our cultural
betters have no idea what the hell
they're talking about
Melinda Gates the wife of Bill Gates
tweeted out a piece from the New York
Times Sunday opinion section called what
good dads get away with division of
labor in the home is one of the most
and equity issues of our time yet at
this rate it will be another 75 years
before men do half the work okay so
that's what Melinda Gates is tweeting
out now Melinda Gates seems like a nice
person I mean she spends a lot of time
on charity she says it's time she
tweeted out this article with the
caption it's high change we high time we
change this hashtag equality can't wait
okay well how about this when you're
responsible for creating half of
Microsoft Bill Gates will do half the
housework how about that like the reason
that I'm uptight about all of this
is not because I shirk the housework I
probably do at least 50% of the
housework in my home as I've said many
times my wife is a doctor which means
that her work schedule is actually more
demanding than mine and when I was
living at home as a as a kid my dad did
a lot more housework than my mom so this
does not come from a desire to say that
only women should do housework or
something stupid like that but the idea
that men and women have to do exactly
the same shares of exactly the same
things and that is what equality is is
so stupid it actually undermines the
efficacy of relationships if you wanna
have a good relationship with your
spouse when I have a good relationship
with your boyfriend or girlfriend the
way to do that is to assume that all
Duty is upon you having expectations of
your partner is actually a big mistake
you should marry somebody who you know
will do this stuff just like when you
hire an employee okay spouse is not an
employee but the same standard actually
obtains here when I hire an employee I
hire the employee with the understanding
that that employee knows more about
their topic of expertise than I do
that's why I'm hiring them if I could do
it myself I wouldn't also I hire them
with the expectation that they're going
to do their job and then I can trust
them to do their job if I have to sit
over them yelling at them and haranguing
them then that's gonna be a problem well
in marriage you should marry somebody
who you believe is going to take
responsibility and help you out it
shouldn't be well Maya
you know I'm gonna force this person to
change now and do half the housework bad
mistake and the same thing is to review
you should assume that if something
needs to get done it's on you to do it
and then if you want to change that you
have a discussion with your spouse but
according to this study women are deeply
put upon because they tend to do more of
the housework you know what else women
tend to do more take time off from work
stay home after they have kids be home
more care more about that sort of stuff
by polling
all of this is true and yet we have this
entire article from the New York Times
now endorsed by Melissa gates the the
the articles by dr. Darcy Lockman it is
dr. Lachman is the author of the
forthcoming all the rage mothers fathers
and the myth of equal partnership and
the piece says quote when my husband and
I became parents a decade ago we were
not prepared for the ways in which
sexism was about to express itself in
our relationship like me he was
enthralled by our daughters like him
I worked outside the home and yet I was
the one who found myself in charge of
managing the details of our children's
lives too often I'd spent frantic days
looking for spring break child care only
to hear him ask oh there's no school
tomorrow or we'd arrive home late with
too tired kids and instead of
spearheading their nighttime routine he
disappeared to brush his own teeth
unless I pointed out these lapses which
he'll tell you I often did and I'll tell
you I often did not he was unaware we've
all heard this story before thinking
about my own relationship and watching
other couples I knew I kept wondering
why is this still happening well maybe
because very often women care more about
a lot of these details in children's
lives than men do and there is a
biological component to such behavior
but I guess we're supposed to believe
that this is all about evil men you're
right and the most woke enlightened
feminists period in American history
it's just the men assume that women are
gonna fill all the gaps when it comes to
childbearing and child-rearing well then
maybe maybe it's your fault maybe you
married a guy who should have swept up
after you maybe this is a you problem
lady maybe there are a lot of women who
are perfectly happy being in
relationships with husbands raising kids
where we understand that we are not all
doing the same amount of work on every
different front and my wife as I say is
working longer hours than I am she also
does more child planning like daily
activity planning when it comes to my
kids I tend to do more of the bedtime
routine and more of the wake up routine
in a partnership with your spouse you
are doing and what you can to help out
the other spouse and if your husband's
not doing that again you're the one who
picked him lady she says the optimistic
tale of the modern involved dad has been
greatly exaggerated the amount of child
care men performed rose throughout the
1980s and 90s but then began to level
off without ever reaching parity mothers
still shoulder sixty five percent of
child care work okay
and fathers still work a
disproportionate number of hours in
academic journals family researchers
caution the culture of fatherhood has
changed more than fathers actual
behavior sociologists attribute the
discrepancy between mother's
expectations and reality to be largely
successful male resistance this
resistance is not being led by socially
conservative men whose like-minded wives
often explicitly agree to take the lead
in the home right it turns out that when
you agree with your spouse you have a
happier marriage so hilariously enough
conservatives tend to be okay with you
know the decisions they make in getting
married
it is only leftists who apparently are
upset about this or liberal she says it
is happening instead with relatively
progressive couples and it takes many
women who thought their partners had
made a prenatal commitment to equal
parenting by surprise why are their
partners failing to pitch in more the
answer lies in part in the different
ways that men and women typically
experience unfairness inequality makes
everyone feel bad studies have found
that people who feel that are getting
away with something experienced fewer
and self-reproach while people who feel
exploited are angry and resentful and
yet men are more comfortable than women
with the first scenario and less
tolerant than women of finding
themselves with the short end of the
stick parody is hard and this
discrepancy lays the groundwork for male
resistance okay there is something
delicious about the idea that the people
who are most victimized here are liberal
women who married the nice feminist men
who paid all of the lip service to
everything was going to be identical and
then just didn't show up for work
there's something slightly ironic about
that if we were going to engage in irony
but the idea that men and women are
supposed to be doing exactly the same
share of everything is really really
dumb hey I'm gonna take the hutt lion's
share when it comes to when it comes to
rough play with my children this is true
for all fathers the disproportionate
share of that goes to me when it comes
to throwing my kids around and tossing
them on the couch and tickling them and
playing sports with them and taking them
swimming and taking them biking that
sort of stuff is going to fall to me
when it comes time for somebody to sit
and do artwork with my daughter that's
probably gonna fall on mommy
men and women are different and that's
okay in fact it's quite good it's one of
the reasons you need a mom and a dad
they are not supposed to be identical
one of the beautiful things about
conservatism is it recognizes the truth
of human nature the truth of human
nature also recognizes that we are not
widgets we are not identical widgets
interchangeable at will that's not the
way this works
so is it a huge problem that women are
disproportionately doing housework it's
only a problem if it's a problem for you
in your relationship but otherwise is it
a generalized societal problem no I'm
sorry it's not you involved yourself in
a voluntary arrangement if you don't
like how that worked out that is a you
choice not a me choice it's not a me
problem frankly work out your marital
problems yourself stop whining about how
it's it's generalized sexism that has
men not doing the brushing of the teeth
at night so this sort of this sort of
Sol abscissa
well it's you know I my own marriage is
a problem therefore it's a problem for
everyone maybe it's not maybe not in a
second we will move on to actual
politics we'll talk about Joe Biden who
is jumping in the polls and we have some
some other cultural issues to discuss
but first it can be a little frustrating
especially if you're in a hurry or
running late to find yourself at a
railway crossing waiting for a train and
if the signals are going and the trains
not even there yet you can feel a bit
tempted to try and sneak across the
tracks don't do it ever this would be a
very stupid decision by you trains are
often going a lot faster than you expect
them to be they cannot stop even if the
engineer hits the brakes right away it
can take a train over a mile to stop by
that time what used to be your car is
just a crunk crushed hunk of metal and
what used to be you well you're a pile
of meat the point is you can't know how
quickly the train will arrive the train
can't stop even if it sees you the
result can be disaster and death if the
signals are on the train is on its way
assume the signals are smarter than you
are because they probably are and you
need to remember one thing you need to
stop because the trains can't the this
warning sounds superfluous to lots of
intelligent people okay well maybe it is
and maybe it's not
I actually know about people who've
tried to run stop signs try it's tried
to run the signals when the train is
coming down the tracks it has ended
quite poorly do not be one of these
people you need to stop when the signal
is down alright so in a second we're
gonna get to another cultural issue
we're a cultural betters are going to
inform us this of course would be
abortion we'll get to that in just one
second first you're gonna have to go
over to Daly where calm and subscribe
when you do you get the rest of this
show live you get the rest of the end
rule Clavin show live the Matt Walsh
Alive two additional hours of me in the
afternoons oh yeah I forgot about
Michael Molesey show that exists as well
you get two additional hours of me every
afternoon when you subscribe you get to
correspond with me in the mail
you also get our Sunday specials on
Saturday we just filmed a great Sunday
special yesterday we have all sorts of
fantastic stuff when you become a
subscriber when you get the annual $99 a
year cheaper than the monthly you get
this
the leftist here is hot or cold tumbler
cast her eyes upon its magnificence I
mean this could be yours so what exactly
are you waiting for makes julienne fries
it's incredible go check it out right
now and when you do you get all of the
aforementioned benefits also please
subscribe a YouTube or iTunes if you
enjoy the show let everybody else know
about it we are not only the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the United States we are the second
ranked podcast in the United States over
the last month helped make us number one
by subscribing and leaving us a review
at iTunes and SoundCloud and YouTube and
anywhere else that you listen to
podcasts thanks so much again we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
again the culture worse in the United
States were one of the main reasons for
the gap in the United States a lot of
people try to attribute the gap in
American thinking to economics you've
seen this increasingly the Trump
revolution was really about dispossessed
small towns that decided they had had
enough of being jobbed by Mexico and
China and they just spoke up in favor of
Trump and they shifted from Obama to
Trump these are these these towns that
are they're the opioid epidemic towns
the addiction centers the suicide
centers they're going to Trump because
of economic issues I don't think that's
true I think that a lot of these places
are going to Trump because they are sick
of being looked down upon by they're
supposed to cultural butters I think the
deplorable pitch by Hillary Clinton was
the worst thing she did during that
campaign just as I think that the Mitt
Romney 47% gaffe during the 2012
campaign was probably the worst thing
that he did he may have been accurate in
terms of the percentages but it felt
like he was looking down at a bunch of
people who felt left behind well over
the course of 2012 to 2016 Barack Obama
made a very solid pitch and so did many
members of the mainstream media along
the lines of Susan Sontag that America
was not an inherently very good place
and that in fact the there was a new
demographic emerging majority that was
going to come up and sweep through the
lands and that we could forget about all
of these deplorable blue-collar white
voters living in small towns who were
abandoned had they they should be left
to the past and we should move on
progressively into the future I think
that drove a lot of the Trump movement I
think it continues to drive a lot of the
Trump movement and I don't think that's
wrong I think there are a lot of people
who are saying listen we're just as
American as you are and in fact many of
our ideals are closer to founding ideals
and traditional morality than the
proposals of people writing for the New
York Times editorial board or members of
the Obama administration so y'all can
just you know stick it where the Sun
don't shine and I think that holds
particularly true when you see members
of the left doing stuff like they are
doing on abortion so the entire left has
now endorsed the hard left has endorsed
abortions whole points of birth which is
a grave moral evil and then they have
informed everybody that if you oppose
them it's because you dislike women and
because you are actually morally
inferior which is an amazing statement
one of the people doing this is a guy
named Pennsylvania's state
representative Brian Simms so over the
last couple of days he is engaged in
some pretty ridiculous behavior this is
this was real
least by live-action but it was Sims
himself who taped it Skye's a Democrat
obviously he what he found in elderly
anti-abortion protesters and started
harassing her hi everyone
representative Brian Sims here and I'm
once again out in front of Planned
Parenthood of southeastern Pennsylvania
today's protester now she is an old lady
trying to avoid showing you her face but
the same laws and luckily that protect
her from being out here also protect me
from showing you who she is you can pry
it at home for children it's probably
the same place you can feed a child but
you're not instead you're out here
shaming people personally that they have
a constitutional right to do who'd have
thought that an old white lady would be
out in front of a Planned Parenthood
telling people what's right for their
bodies shame on you shame on you for
hiding your face at the same time you're
shaming other people okay well the
reason she's hiding her face is because
she was wearing a docs by people like
this Pennsylvania State Representative
who's harassing an elderly anti-abortion
protester who's literally just standing
there and telling people that maybe they
want to think about what it is they are
doing and then this guy went even
further he offered money for the
identities of teenagers who are
protesting against abortion and I'm the
media was fine with slandering the
Covington Catholic students for standing
there and doing nothing have you heard
any national coverage of this
Pennsylvania elected state
representative Democrat who's now
offering money for the identities of
teenagers so that they can be doxxed
teenagers a bunch of pseudo Christian
protesters who've been out here shaming
young girls for being here here's the
deal I've got a hundred dollars to
anybody who will identify any of these
three don't need to look what you're
doing nothing at all about what you're
doing hi nothing Christian are loving
for God
about what you're doing so I've got $100
to anybody who will identify $100 see if
you got some friends out here a hundred
bucks it'd be easier if you'd just give
me your name in your address
what makes you think that it's your job
to tell women what's right for their
body and the truth is I'm not really
asking because I don't care shame on you
okay so this guy is standing outside an
abortion clinic harassing people who are
attempting to inform people about the
decision they're about to make and then
he's offering money to Doc's teenagers
these are our moral betters well what a
nice has any Democrat by the way been
asked about this imagine if a Republican
representative were to do the same thing
at for example a pro-choice rally let's
say there is a pro-choice rally at a
church and the pro-choice the
pro-choicers were standing outside
holding signs how do you think it would
go off a pro-life person walked up to
that group a pro-life elected
representative and started daxing the
kids in that group you think that would
go great again these are these are the
people whose morality we should
certainly concede to the people who
sneer at the Bible people who suggest
that if you are anti-abortion and
religious that that is because you are
secretly a bigot and your religion is
simply bigotry and this culture gap
matters folks and everybody who's under
estimating the culture gap and trying to
reduce it down to economic concerns is
totally missing the boat missing the
boat in a huge way politically and
exacerbating divides in the country I'd
venture to say that that culture divide
issues ranging from the kind of scorn of
celebrities in Hollywood to people
harassing anti-abortion protesters
outside clinics that that has as much to
do with voting patterns as economics
does in the United States which is one
of the reasons why I think that the best
candidate for the Democrats would be
somebody who doesn't do all of this
stuff who isn't part of the woke scold
left who isn't involved in this ironic
breaking down of all standards who
doesn't consider themselves part of the
morally insular echo chamber anybody who
does that has a shot at winning a
general election anybody who doesn't is
gonna have a real tough time against
President Trump and this brings us to
the latest polls so I think the polls
are showing this Joe Biden is dominating
the latest polls he's dominant among
Democrats he's dominating them Joe Biden
has now 46% of the vote in the National
Democratic
primary poll according to Harris X and
the hill he is followed by Bernie
Sanders who's fallen all the way down to
14% and then people who to judge at 8%
Elizabeth Warren at 7% Harris at 6% and
everybody else at 3% or below Biden is a
dominating frontrunner one of the
reasons that Biden is a dominating
frontrunner is because if you watch Joe
Biden's launch ad if you watched his
launch at which I said I thought was in
many ways quite good one of the things
that you notice is that this was
somebody who was not trying to cast
Americans as bad if they disagreed with
him on politics he was trying to suggest
there's a moral conflict in the country
and then he was mischaracterizing
President Trump in order to do so but in
terms of what he was promoting he was
saying America has been based on these
true good and eternal principles and
that we all share those principles
that's a conservative message and that's
what Americans want to hear it's why
he's continuing to do well there's a new
morning console poll again shows Biden
at 40% and Bernie Sanders at 19
everybody else below 10 that's pretty
incredible lead for Joe Biden the reason
he is largely seen as the most electable
Democrat is because he is not engaged at
least publicly right now and this sort
of ironically detached scorning and
looking down his nose at the vast
majority of Americans in the middle it
was the reason by the way that I was
first kind to Pete would judge his
candidacy because when he first started
one of the first comments that he made
was that as a gay man he needed to check
for legs they have good chicken and I
thought oh well a rational human being
who's not trying to demonize his fellow
Americans now since then people who
judge has decided he needs to swivel to
the radical left and so he has started
to attack Mike Pence as a bigot and
suggest that religious Americans who
believe in traditional marriage are
bigots I thought it's a bad political
move I also think it's a bad moral move
but the appeal of Buddha judge
originally was the same as Biden's
appeal which was again not trying his
ironic detachment from the sincere lives
of millions of Americans so the if
Democrats actually want to win they're
gonna have to get over this this belief
that their moral superiority makes them
capable of sneering and everyone else
and that was the feeling about Hillary
Clinton among Republicans by the ways
that Hillary Clinton spent her entire
career sneering at people who are not
like Hillary Clinton and that goes all
the way back to the 1990s when she was
suggesting that stay-at-home moms were
stand by your man women like Tammy white
that Hillary had a long history of that
it's one of the reasons Biden is more
popular than Hillary because he hasn't
really said stuff like that
Hillary used to say that sort of stuff
routinely the more you're in the bubble
the more you're the kind of person who
looks down at the sincere authentic
belief systems of other Americans belief
systems that have deep roots in American
life and says to those people you know
I'm just gonna mock you
because really what you are is a
trailer-trash person who likes pink
flamingos I'm gonna wear this pink
flamingos to this weird Met Gala in
order so that I can make fun of you I'm
doing exam sophisticated and ironic
you're doing it because you're a dope
that sort of culture gap matters Joe
Biden has an engagement yet and that's
one of the reasons that Joe Biden is a
dangerous candidate now the problem is
of course the Joe Biden comes along with
policies so Joe Biden said yesterday his
first mission like his very first thing
as president of the United States would
be to repeal the tax cuts well good luck
with that it turns out the tax cuts have
helped some 80% of Americans I speak
again as someone who is not invested
personally in the tax cuts I paid more
taxes thanks to the tax cuts because
state tax the state taxes are no longer
deductible on federal income tax but
when Joe Biden says he wants to repeal
tax cuts bold move Joe let's see how it
plays out for you people say well Joe
how you do all this well guess what
first thing I do is gonna repeal this
Trump tax cut oh not a joke hey taxes
more whoo so that's that's good stuff
right there by the way Joe Biden is now
undergoing another another problem Jill
Biden his wife who seems like a nice
person she just told NPR this morning
that it's time to move beyond the Anita
the Anita Hill question so Joe Biden who
used to be enough of an honest broker I
guess that he recognized that Anita Hill
was lying in parts of her testimony now
he's gonna get excoriated for it by the
same radical left that sneers and
everybody else so Joe Biden is is saying
that sort of stuff as I've said I think
that the best day for Joe Biden these
are these are the salad days for Joe
Biden I am not sure that it is not
downhill for Joe Biden I'm not sure that
the left will tolerate any candidate who
doesn't channel their feeling of deep
rage at this group of people in the
middle of the country who refuse to go
along with the program
of movement sort of brighter future that
involves ironically looking down at half
of Americans Joe Biden called Anita Hill
as we know but she said she didn't
consider that call an apology
and now Joe Biden says well you know we
need to get beyond that she said quote I
watched the hearings like most other
Americans and I mean joe said as did I I
believe to need a hill he voted against
Clarence Thomas he apologized for the
way the hearings were run now it's kind
of time to move on and then she says
well he wanted to call her not because
he was running for president but out of
sincerity the left is going to just tear
him limb from limb now maybe he survives
maybe there are enough rational
Democrats left in the party that Joe
Biden is the nominee maybe not maybe not
because it seems it seems like not it
seems like the the amount of rage and on
stand the Democratic Party is too high
maybe for Joe Biden to be able to carry
this sort of support all the way through
the primaries Kamala Harris still trying
to channel that rage and anger she came
out yesterday and she said Trump isn't
trying to make America great Trump is
trying to make America hate said this at
the end double-a-c-p
this guy in the White House said
neo-nazis were fine people when they
marched on Charlottesville he's attacked
communities of color and leaders of
color by name
he's denigrated entire countries on the
continent of Africa with foul language
no president should speak let's speak
truth here and today this president
isn't trying to make America great he's
trying to make America hate okay this is
the same woman who suggests that stacey
abrams is legitimate governor of georgia
that that andrew Gilliam is legitimate
governor of Florida and that voter
suppression has been breaking out across
America against black people I mean this
is a very divisive personality I wonder
if that divisive Ness is going to
continue to take over the Democratic
Party okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today I'm gonna make
the very controversial and bold
statement I thought the last episode of
Game of Thrones is really good I know so
if you haven't seen
Game of Thrones if you're not a Game of
Thrones fan then prepare yourself for
three minutes of me talking about Game
of Thrones there will be spoilers
included so Game of Thrones is the the
last episode the Battle of Winterfell
not in Fayed not a huge fan I understand
why people liked it but it was basically
World War Z shot through a potato
zombie battle terrible battle tactics
everyone lived except for like two
people who we knew were gonna die anyway
this last episode was hit return to what
made Game of Thrones interesting in the
first place
which was all the intrapersonal play and
it was all of the characters being true
to themselves so Dany is smart and
ambitious but her ambition is her
greatest problem because she desperately
wants to be queen
and as Varys my hero in the show the
only libertarian in the show says the
only person who should be king or queen
is the person who doesn't want to be
king or queen which is a very
Cincinnatus George Washington type thing
to say I've said it myself about the
presidency so Jon Snow is that character
Jon Snow however happens to have the
stark streak of doltish ness in him so
Jon wants Dany to be the queen but Jon
also does not take her advice about
keeping his face shut until he decides
to tell his sisters that he is in fact
the true heir to the Targaryen throne
which turns out as a bad move Ned Stark
kept the secret for some thirty years
Sansa Stark kept it for thirty two
seconds before she proceeded to tell
Tyrion and initiate what will be the
final the final problem of people trying
to kill Danny Danny going crazy burning
people alive Jon having to kill her
that's the way that I think that this
probably goes unfortunately but that's
that's the direction but all of that all
of that makes some sense the killing of
Danny's other dragon I know people had a
problem with it oh why why couldn't you
see the ships coming
why didn't she know that they were going
to shoot have newfangled versions of
these giant bolts why didn't she know
any of that okay fine if you can't
suspend your disbelief for that fine but
the dragon had to go and the fact that
the dragon went down obviously is
driving Danny toward the feeling that
she is alone in the world and so she's
back where she began on the show alone
in the world except this time she has a
dragon and an army so that is where the
show is going I like all of that stuff
obviously there are very awkward moments
like Jaime and Brienne what yeah it is a
it is a bug of boo of mine that for some
reason Hollywood writers think that
all male female friendships have to end
in sex it's weird
why can't Breanna and Jamie just be
friends and hehe understands that she's
an honorable woman and she looks more
honourable than then Circe does why does
he have to sleep with her it's just all
it's it's very strange and a weird turn
of character from Jamie but overall I
really like this show a lot better one
final critique of the show there's no
way that Cersei doesn't kill Tyrion at
the end of that that episode right I
mean Tyrion is standing right below the
walls
she's just deployed Bronn to kill him
she's got him directly in range of her
archers and instead of killing him she
lets him go to kill Musante why so he
can live and then go advise Daenerys it
doesn't make any sense it would have
been an amazing moment by the way if
they actually had the stones to kill
Tyrion right there cuz he's had is his
kind of final flaw is that he still
thinks that his family is loyal that
would have been the greatest it really
would've been original game 1 season
that Thrones kind of stuff but overall
much better we're back to the character
study we're back to the part of the
story that matters so all of that is
good haters don't at me okay other
things that I like today so you know
let's make this a thing that I hate
actually so Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
they're they're a couple things that I
hate with regard to a OC I don't hate
her she seems like a delightful human
who doesn't know things and says don't
crap all the time but apparently there
was there there's a parody account of a
OC that has now been banned from Twitter
even though it was clearly linked as a
parody account it clearly indicated
itself as parody in the Twitter name
Twitter name it had 85,000 followers
Twitter shut it down for unclear reasons
the political who created a man the
account according to Daily wire Mike
Morrison also had his personal account
permanently banned
according to screenshots provided by
Morrison Twitter acknowledges that
clearly marked parody accounts are
allowed a Morrison's content posted to
the AOC parody account was apparently
too similar to comments actually made by
the socialists so in other words him pay
she was impossible to parody is
basically the critique the critique is
that she says such dumb stuff that any
attempt to parody her sounds too much
like her so that that's pretty amazing
and it's a pretty great indicator of how
awful she is at her job in other news
AOC has discovered garbage disposals
some
exciting so she should put out a video
yesterday talking about garbage
disposals with the caption this DC
apartment is bougie and has things I've
never seen before like what is a garbage
disposal really for is it better or
worse than throwing something in the
garbage more importantly why is it so
loud and yelling at me okay a couple of
things one apparently garbage disposals
have been illegal in New York City since
1997 um what the hell is wrong with your
city a question I'm from Los Angeles
everybody's got a garbage disposal why
are they illegal why is your city
ridiculous why would you outlaw garbage
disposals also what are garbage
disposals for aside from awkward scenes
in final destination well they're
obviously for disposing of the garbage
that accrues in your sink when you wash
a dish that's what a garbage just like
it's not rocket science the good news I
guess and we can play the video for a
second garbage disposal I've never seen
a garbage disposal I never had one in
any place I've ever lived it is
terrifying I don't know what T did for
or what its purpose is
like food scraps like is this
environmentally sound I don't know oh
okay so she doesn't know well I'll tell
you what I'm just glad she's discovered
a great place to store her policy
proposals that's what I really care
about so so good on AOC for finally
finding a place you can put her policy
proposals directly in the garbage
disposal and save us all plenty of time
already well we will be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours or we will see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey guys over on the show today a
democratic state representative in
Pennsylvania maybe you've seen this guy
this video of him harassing and
intimidating and daxing pro-life
protesters outside of a Planned
Parenthood in Philadelphia well we're
gonna respond to that and hundreds of us
are going to show up to that Planned
Parenthood clinic to maybe teach this
guy a lesson about bullying
I'll have info on that event it's pretty
exciting stuff so tune in for that also
Cory Booker is calling for gun
confiscation but I thought that
Democrats always say that no they're not
going to take our guns well apparently
they are so we'll talk about that as
well today over on the Matt Walsh show